it's time to add the following to the
definition of the word pro a word
attached to the end of a technology
product to denote that this thing is
better faster and more suited for the
workplace than this other thing also
typically associated with a stylus
because pros love pens there's the Apple
iPad pro there's the Microsoft Surface
pro and now there's this five hundred
and fifty dollar Samsung Chromebook pro
like the others it tries to be a laptop
a tablet and a sketchpad all-in-one
overall I'm pretty Pro the Chromebook
pro but there are some major cons you
should know about before buying let's
start with what's good number one design
the 2.4 pound laptop is really compact
and pretty easy to flip back and hold as
a tablet - it also has a beautiful
twelve point three inch touchscreen the
shape is closer to a square than a
rectangle but who doesn't miss square
screens number two a stylus it comes
with a pen so you can write on the
screen it can lag a bit compared to the
iPad pencil but I still give it a big
thumbs up for note-taking number 3
battery life I got close to 7 and a half
hours on a charge plus it uses USB C for
fast charging and future-proofing number
for Chrome OS with an Intel M processor
the browser-based operating system is
snappy I also like all the latest tricks
for handling multiple apps next the cons
and ironically from OS can be one of the
biggest ones for the Chromebook pro
number one Chrome OS Android apps this
is one of the first Chromebooks to run
Android apps exciting except they can be
very slow and buggy yes I would love to
restart this app for the tenth time then
they can't be resized so you're stuck
with a phone sized app or a Super
Stretch tab number two tablet the app
issue means as a tablet the Samsung
simply isn't as good as the iPad pro
number three keyboard well I'd rather
type on this thing than the iPad smart
keyboard cover I have to do it when
there's still daylight
right no back lane for now to Samsung
Chromebook Pro is a better laptop and
tablet but Google does promise some
fixes for the apps situation until then
maybe Pro should stand for across the
nation